years ago I was told I may never be able
to have sex again
[Music]
lying on my back with my legs in the
stirrups I could feel my body start to
shake the doctor wheeled over to me and
told me that she was going to poke me
with a q-tip and the next thing I knew
my whole body felt like it was in flames
it felt like someone had stabbed it with
a steel rod what are you doing I asked
her she said all I did was touch you
with this q-tip she took her hand away
from my vagina to her gloves off and
looked at me it looks like you have
vaginismus and definitely simple but
Dania I had no idea what she was talking
about you have a condition that causes
chronic pain in your vagina and during
insertion you have another condition
that causes pain with that there is
currently no cure for the condition what
am I supposed to do then give me a pill
give me something that I can do she
didn't give me a solution I first
discovered my vagina problems when I was
just a young girl going to the
gynecologist
I thought the pain that I was feeling
during the annual exam was totally
normal and that everyone felt that type
of pain when their vagina was being
touched a few years later when I started
using tampons and couldn't and felt an
immeasurable amount of pain I thought
that was normal too despite the pain
that I was experiencing I never once
thought to ask my friends hey when you
go to the gynecologist does it feel like
you're being ripped open from the inside
out I kind of just ignored it and went
about my life and didn't think much
about my vagina until a few years later
when I started to be really interested
in boys your first time having sex is
pretty much supposed to hurt that's what
everyone tells you it's what I've heard
since I was like 13 years old it hurts
like hell but when I tried and it hurts
so badly that I was screaming out in
pain I thought is this really what it's
supposed to be like as I got older and I
tried to experiment more and more the
same thing kept happening eventually the
pain was so bad and embarrassing that I
just shied away from pretty much any
sort of physical interaction with boys
at all after being in a situation where
I had to cry out in pain and leave
awkwardly from a room with someone who
had no idea what was going on I didn't
want to be in that situation eventually
after shying away from guys so often I
met someone that I did care about a lot
and I wanted to try again because when
you really like someone you want to be
intimate with them I thought maybe it
was just the first couple of guys maybe
it was just a fluke maybe my vagina was
better
now but it wasn't and after another
embarrassing and super painful
experience where he asked what the hell
was wrong with me I finally realized
maybe I needed to figure it out
I made an appointment with a
gynecologist that week I went in knowing
that something was wrong
I left hearing the word endometriosis
endometriosis was something I had never
heard of but it was apparently likely
that I had it while doing the surgery it
was confirmed that I did in fact have
endometriosis lesions all over my
ovaries and uterus and that I should be
better now I went through the surgery I
wasn't supposed to have pain anymore
as the week's went by post-surgery the
pain only got worse at the time I was
still with the guy that I'd really cared
about and kept trying which was why I
kind of thought to go through with the
surgery but due to the lack of intimacy
and the fact that I had no idea what the
hell was wrong with my vagina the
relationship was disintegrating before
my eyes I felt like I had nothing to
offer him physically and I couldn't
understand why he would still want to be
with me I felt guilty like I was doing
something wrong he didn't understand why
I was shying away from every single
touch or refusing to be intimate at all
and I didn't have an explanation for him
I had gone for the surgery I thought I
knew what was wrong with me so what the
hell was going on was it all mental
physical pain often brings its best
friend emotional pain and obviously when
someone is in that amount of pain day
after day depression kind of creeps its
way in and takes over your life at the
time of this all happening I was 21
years old I was a senior in college I
was supposed to be having the time of my
life going out all the time meeting cute
boys getting cool internships and like
living it up for the last semester of
college instead I spent almost every day
in bed in pain wondering what the hell
was wrong with me and pleading with a
higher power to give me an answer
I lost my appreciation for life simple
things became too much I didn't get out
of bed to go to the dining hall to eat
dinner I barely hung out with my friends
I basically closed myself off from
everyone in my life I wanted to think
about my future I wanted to have a good
time but instead all I could think about
was the pain that was stemming from my
vagina and now taking over my entire
body so while my friends took the party
bus downtown to go to the bars on a
Thursday night I tried to distract
myself as much as I could most of the
time I would watch TV but it seemed like
every scene on TV reminded me some way
of my pain my friends eventually stopped
asking me to hang out
not that I blamed them and I stopped
pretending to be okay altogether a
couple of months went by and suddenly it
was May and I was supposed to be
graduating soon I could not think about
the rest of my life or even the next
week without thinking what the hell am I
gonna do about this pain so I decided to
pull out the big guns and go to Mayo
Clinic in Rochester Minnesota Mayo
Clinic is supposed to be the best of the
best and I felt like I didn't have any
other choice and I don't think I've ever
felt so desperate in my life I was
begging them please please can you help
me the doctor wheeled her chair around
again and turned to face me at this
point I was practically hyperventilating
I was crying so hard she had told me
something that was wrong with me but it
was just a bunch of jumble of words that
meant nothing to me and when she said
there's no definitive cure I felt my
heart drop out of my body I can't tell
you that you will ever be free of this
she said but there are things that you
can do unfortunately I had stopped
listening when she said she wasn't sure
I would be free of this all I could
think about was my exes and all the ways
that they had looked
when I disappointed them over and over
again is this what I'm gonna have to go
through the rest of my life I didn't
want to schedule more appointments I
didn't want to be at this place anymore
I just wanted to go home and forget that
this had ever happened
I honestly hoped that it was a nightmare
but when I woke up the next morning
still in Rochester Minnesota and
remembered everything she had said to me
I knew it wasn't a nightmare the terms
vulvodynia vaginismus pelvic floor
dysfunction had all been thrown at me
and I had no [ __ ] idea what it meant
was I supposed to be okay with the fact
that I couldn't have sex was I supposed
to be okay with the fact that wearing
tampons hurt just as bad as shoving a
metal rod in flames up my vagina it's
been almost six years since I went to
Mayo Clinic and got that diagnosis it
did actually change my life I slept with
ice on my vagina I only wore cotton
underwear I would go to physical therapy
for my vagina it's really hard when you
have some sort of pain day after day to
think of anything but that pain watching
sex scenes on TV or hearing about sex
kind of makes me feel like I want to
throw up and it's not because it's like
new sex that's gross it's because I feel
broken and I feel like a part of me is
missing a part of me that I never once
got to experience
truth be told to this day it's still
incredibly difficult to witness
conversations about sex or talk about it
at all
I've made a lot of progress but I'm
still not having penetration the more I
open up about these conditions though
the more I realized that I'm definitely
not alone and they're actually pretty
common a lot of people aren't having sex
the way that we think that they're
having sex in fact I'd say that most
people aren't I will always continue to
believe that there is much more to life
than the ability to have sex and I will
continue to try to convince any person
despite sex despite abilities that you
are still worth loving no matter what it
definitely doesn't mean that you're
broken when I look in the mirror I know
that I am lovable despite not being able
to have sex and I know someday I'll be
able to forgive my body for letting me
down I'm not quite there yet some days
are better than others but I know I'll
get there someday
hey I'm sob is on a new channel I know
your part so describe here that was my
part